everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we were
going to do some work with jQuery it's
been a while since we've done anything
with jQuery but I built a single page
application 2016 I worked on it for on
and off for the majority of 2016 I think
I launched it in October September
something like that yeah it had to have
been October I think I launched it right
around when my youngest daughter was
born so she was born at the beginning of
October hey everyone
see a lot of you the live chat so before
we do that I have a few things I want to
talk about I'm gonna try to keep it
quick and then we can talk more about it
later on when we do the question and
answer session so first thing is
something cool I found this in my
basement and this is like my first phone
the first one I ever had so it's one of
these old Nokia phones with like the
clear case that I thought was so awesome
I mean it I still think it's awesome you
see all the insides and the buttons are
worn down you can't see the numbers on
some of them so anyway I'm gonna add
this to my antique collection which you
all can't see so up here so this is my
antique collection up here I just have a
bunch of like floppy disk beta tapes the
copy of Windows XP and I you can't see
it but I have an old like CRT like
television with a VCR and it so so
that's going to be added to the
collection and I'm gonna see if I can
find a cord that will charge that and
I'll get back on it
maybe I can look at all my old text
messages and see what I was saying when
I was a teenager maybe I'll play some
snake y'all remember snake all right so
that was that was something fun now
something serious and then I want to
talk about a project that I'm working on
and see if anyone's interested in being
involved so something serious I know
I've talked on the stream before about
mental health issues with myself having
depression so I just want to like fill
you in on what I've been doing and I've
been in a much better mood recently so
as you may or may not know from previous
streams I am going to counseling every
month I'm on in two different
antidepressants so I'm doing you know
basically medically what I should be
doing but then in addition to that this
is now the tenth day in a row that I
have got up early before work and
exercise
so nothing intense I just go on an
exercise bike while I play Zelda on my
Nintendo switch and I just go for like
half hour 45 minutes just as long as I
can before the kids wake up and and then
afterwards I may do some push-ups or
sit-ups if I have time and do a little
stretching and I'm not super tired
during the day I mean I stay caffeinated
right so but I'm not really tired from
waking up like this morning I got up at
4:45 a.m. and I feel fine right now so
anyway I just want to share that with
you all I know it's pretty common
knowledge that exercise helps with your
mood and with depression but sometimes
it just takes a little push to get going
so this is kind of my little push to say
hey I've been doing enough for 10 days I
feel a whole lot better it was really
really hard at first to get out of bed
but now that I got into a rhythm I'm
waking up early before my alarm
the key also is getting the bed on time
so I've been taking melatonin at night
so that I can go to sleep early enough
to make that possible I'm still not
sleeping like a lot like seven hours or
so like give or take a half hour but you
know if I can get eight that's awesome
too but anyway so that's just decide
bring that up I haven't really talked
about mental health issues on the stream
for a while and I know you know some of
you may be dealing with the same things
it's pretty common so just just want to
talk about if anyone wants to talk more
about that either in the chat or
privately you know feel free to reach
out to me I've been dealing with it for
a long time and sometimes it does help
to be able to talk to somebody who's
going through the same thing alright so
last thing before we get started with
the code as you all know if you've been
watching the last few streams I
purchased the domain name JavaScript AF
and we have a forum running on there now
that Harshit set up which is awesome
thank you harsh it right now
it was down because we were trying to
transfer it from harsh it's digitalocean
account to mine and took a snapshot try
to transfer it didn't work so he just
sent me another snapshot and we're gonna
try to get that up and running so okay I
see this hard should I see the snapshot
now thank you I guess I'll just get that
up and running after the stream so we're
going to try to get that up so if you're
trying to get to the forum don't worry
it's we're working on it it should be up
soon after the stream but I've had so
javascript err so you can see job it's
in the live chat right now Jay
s-see RP or JV SC rptr so I'm just gonna
say JavaScript I reached out to me on
Instagram and had an idea for a website
where developers can connect with
developers and it would be like like a
social media platform but you'd login
with your github profile and it could
you could voluntarily have a pool data
from your github and mix that in so I I
kind of envisioned it and and JavaScript
you can let you know you know more
details as well in terms of like the UI
and things and what's going on but the
way I envisioned it is it's gonna be
place pretty much just for developers
right you have to at least have a github
account to get in so if if you don't
remember Facebook when it first started
around like 2004 somewhere around there
you had to have a university email and
at first like you had to have your
university signed up to get an email not
not every university was even allowed
yet so it was like this niche and it was
kind of cool you you had this thing in
common so trying to go for that vibe of
you know this is a place just for a
certain niche so it's it's not we're not
trying to recreate Facebook here or
Twitter or anything like that they all
serve their purpose and what we're
trying to do here is just have a place
more geared toward developers so the
features would be developers for
developers for instance like all the
github info I think it would be cool I
had another suggestion for someone on
Twitter and I'm really sorry I can't
remember who it was right now but
another suggestion was to feature really
awesome JavaScript projects from the
community so I think that's another
thing that we could work in so that made
when you go there it's not all about
it's not just all about your feed like
Facebook or Twitter is there's also like
some highlights from the community of
really cool things going on maybe some
sort of like voting mechanism to be able
to see what's what's going in there and
and I would I kind of want to exclude
like the really big projects everybody
knows reacts a big deal you know so we
wouldn't want to feature that because
I'm sure it would be on top all the time
right when you go to look at like github
like top projects it's always a lot of
the same really big ones so I would kind
of want to feature like some more
unknown things that are really cool like
people doing like VR with JavaScript
machine learning like no bus cool stuff
so anyway we don't need to have all the
features ready right away of course
right but the basic features that we'd
like to have are you know obviously this
is going to be built with react because
that's that's what we've been into new
most often in terms of back-end I'm kind
of thinking maybe firebase would be a
good fit for authentication and things
like that so I don't know let me know
what you all think so while you're
watching the rest of the stream before
we get to the question answer session
just think about this think if it's
maybe something that you'd like to be
involved in in some way or you know what
are your ideas in terms of technology
was what would work best to have
something like this where users sign in
with their github obviously they're
going to need to be data to stored
images stored these things so it if
you're familiar with firebase let me
know if I'm on the right track here in
firebase would be a good fit so
I yeah I don't know so this is it's
still very open in terms of like
architecture like what's what we're
gonna already use so I mean something
like firebase just comes with so many
things built in to help us expand so
that's why I'm kind of mentioning that
but I haven't worked with it personally
I've just kind of watched videos on it
all right so anyway right now JavaScript
er is working on UI stuff so basically
just making kind of an interactive
prototype with just straight HTML like
CSS stuff well eventually once we get
that to where like we like it we can
convert it to react components so that's
that's where we're going now
javascript ER has a repo for the UI up
now so I guess we could share info about
that I'll maybe I'll get a repo going
for like the react version of it and so
we could have like one official place we
can maybe do some have some issues ready
if you want to help with it so I am I'm
going to kind of stop the conversation
on it now so we can get to the get to
the code but then we'll pick up with it
and you know so feel free to type
whatever you think about this project
and please be honest if you think it's a
terrible idea let me know if you if you
have ideas for features or whatever
please let me know and we can discuss it
in the question answer session I'm
probably not going to talk about it all
the time on the stream for two reasons
one this is free code camp stream we
mainly deal with nonprofits this could
eventually end up being a for-profit
thing if it's big I could see maybe
companies wanting to advertise jobs I
wouldn't want it to get crazy like a lot
of social media now there's so many
sponsored posts and things I don't want
it to be like that but you know
potentially there could be something
like some something at some point so I
don't want to bring that into the
we can't Channel also I am streaming
from work and I'd like to work on my
work project so I don't want to spend a
lot of my work time doing this so if you
have questions please feel free to ask
me I'll take a minute or two in the live
chat everyday to talk if you have a
question otherwise just you know send me
a message on any of the social media
things or whatever and we can kind of
organize this and and get this going
okay
also javascript is in the live chat now
so if you want to keep the conversation
going just send a message
you know just tag JavaScript or in the
live chat okay all right so let me
introduce you to this old jQuery project
that I that I built so I we we worked a
little bit on a react version of this
project this is the the bulletin right
the university of oulu team that we had
worked on and i did some updates to it
yesterday i added so we had that email
authentication where you could do the
password list link sent to your email
i've added another way to go into the
app and we talked about this yesterday a
bit where basically if you're able to
log into the university single sign-on
system and get to that password
protected area and then you click the
link from there you can get directly
into the bulletin without having to go
through the normal login process but the
problem now is before we automatically
had a user's email because they had to
put their email in to login and so I had
a form on there that a user could fill
out and I didn't have an email field
because we just grabbed the email
automatically now we need to add an
email field in and we need to change up
a little bit about how we're sending
that data to make sure that the emails
are going where they they need to go so
let's dig into there let's let's kind of
like try to straighten out my spaghetti
code jQuery this hopefully will be a
good example of why you
I really don't want to try to make a
single-page app and handle routing and
everything with jQuery because it starts
out small and then you add new features
in all the sudden there's a lot there so
let's start out and let's run this so
this is running on gulp so haven't used
go up in a while I don't know how many
of you remember using gulp or still use
go I mean if I'm not doing the react
projects I'd probably go with gulp or
maybe just like NPM scripts or something
but so I think it's gulp watch let's see
oops let me bring my screen up here
there we are
yeah so I just did a gulp watch and this
brought up our bulletin now I'm gonna
have to login so here's the the normal
login
and this is done with a service called
auth0
so I'm just using the free plan for
auth0
the university is not very big so the
free plan is sufficient and I'm sending
the emails for the authentication
through SendGrid
so the free plan on Austria and SendGrid
are kind of what's behind this current
system eventually we'll get rid of this
system when we switch over to the react
version that heart should set up a
password the system without the use of
Ozzy row which is awesome so let me
check my email now and get the code
there we go
that's great all right so now I'm in so
what's happened is the user information
is not saved in local storage in the
browser so as long as I don't clear your
local storage then this will stay login
for a year at least that's the plan some
users have been having issues where
their local storage is getting cleared
and there's no apparent reason why so
that was the other day there yesterday
or the day before or I think I had
someone come in for some troubleshooting
and that was exactly the issue they were
getting logged out and we could not
figure out why all right so let's go to
this submit announcement form so this is
what we're going to be changing we just
need to add one more field and that's
for email and we probably could now that
I look at it you I was it might make
more sense visually to move this file up
load up here in this corner so we would
have email the file upload and then the
announcement full-width down here write
the announcement generally tends to be a
lot longer it wouldn't make sense that
will fool with email except on on small
screens all right so that's what we're
that's what we're gonna do so let's
check the code and let me just duplicate
this tab and we're gonna go into visual
studio code I don't think I have this
open anywhere maybe I did oh well okay
so this was our password we don't need
this this is where I'm handling the
login our app
[Music]
baliya so all the code is informs AAS
now unfortunately this code is in a
private repo so you won't be able to to
follow along I just saw the live chat
Harshit said has to go because something
came up
thanks so much are [ __ ] for for all your
help with the forum earlier and
hopefully everything's alright nikki has
to go to see it thanks for watching
let's I also should mention we had some
more pool requests come in and we will
go over that and review that probably
tomorrow I'd like to get back to our
main project that francisc and main
website that we've been working on
tomorrow and then continue to just work
on that project until we launch it in
February late February
alright so let's check out what we have
this controls the modal and we have
different models that show up whether
the message is successful or not we're
also going to need to go to the index
page so let me split this this screen so
we can have the HTML on one place and I
believe it's all the way at the bottom
here
here we are let me know if that font is
too small so we can see we have this
this text area for announcement what we
want to do is make an input so I'm going
to I'm gonna take this and copy it and
we're gonna need yeah we're gonna need
to rearrange this a bit but first how
that indentation is crazy there we are
so we're get definitely going to change
this we don't want the the edit icon so
let's see I'm not sure if there's an
icon called email but it's worth a shot
and we want to change this we obviously
don't need a text area so let's change
this to an input and we can give it a
type of email we want to change the ID
to email and he relies inputs I think
that class will be fine and we want to
change this to an input and the label
now is going to be for email and we're
going to change this to email all right
so now we're pulling in email are we we
have a field for email and let's bring
up this file upload whoops and you know
what I forgot to put this in its own
I mess this up a bit alright let's bring
this down here and let's put it in a div
we are using materialized CSS so that's
where these column classes are coming
from class it's so weird to not type
class name since we're used to doing
react but we can use class and let's
call let's make this a column and we
want it to be in small screens we want
to make it full width so 12 out of 12
columns and then on medium screens and
up we want it to be half the width so 6
out of 12 columns and now we can paste
in our new input and then we also want
to bring in this file upload input so
let's grab make sure it'll grab too much
class for every checkbox okay I believe
we have everything and we're gonna put
this right here underneath and we're
gonna also need to change our column
classes as well so we had the column
that was oops
did I put this in the wrong spot I think
I did
let's move that okay
now in the right spot so we just need to
add on on medium screen so we want this
to take up half the width all right now
let's check out how this looks and then
we can go back to our our code
let's move this around so you don't want
to go too far all right let's check this
all right okay not not too bad
so we have our email and you know what
the this is not aligned correctly we
have to check on this alignment why
we're having an issue here but other
than the alignment issue this looks fine
I do want to make sure we're setting a
good breakpoint here so let's see if at
any point it looks too small I think
it's fine I mean it's getting a little
narrow there but that's that's still
reasonable all right all right not bad
let's see if we can figure out from the
markup with this this issue is beat with
the spacing with these icons and an easy
fix if we can't figure it out would just
be to remove the icons which I'm okay
with doing that basically the reason
being this is a really low level update
that needs to happen so I am I'm not
that worried about you whether or not
there's an icon there all right
so we have this row and everything is
wrapped in one row okay call them class
the field callers - okay it's a column
you know what let's try to put though we
do have this oops
what did we do you know what I added
another column there I did not even
realize that I added an extra column
alright so if anybody caught that and
was really confused that's why I added
an extra column where I didn't really
need one
let's check this up now hopefully that
corrected it yep and that corrected it
now these are lined up properly I'm not
thrilled about how far up this is with
the email but I'm willing to live with
it right now whoa hahaha I didn't even
notice this alright I probably just
forgot an ending div here somewhere so
let's check out our divs
[Music]
oops there we are I have too many divs
here we are
all right that's acceptable I'm honestly
this is not the best-looking thing I've
ever built but right now this needs to
be done like today like this morning it
needs to be done so I'm okay with it
also the fact that we're going to
replace this entire thing with something
new
sometime within the next six months like
I'm alright with with this this is a
feature used by I don't know maybe a
dozen people on campus so it just
doesn't make sense to spend a whole lot
of time nitpicking the details of this
UI alright so now let's make sure that
that email gets in to our forms J s file
so let's see how how we're getting this
data so we can move this over because we
won't really need this just mark up for
a little while let me see I'm gonna
check my time in about five minutes I'm
gonna take a five-minute break and I'm
gonna go to the live shot here and
answer some questions I don't want to
get too far behind with the live chat so
if you're asking questions you're
wondering why I'm not reading your
comments or questions
I usually go back and forth between code
and questions for a certain amount of
time so I do code for about 25 minutes
then I go back to the question and then
at the end I'll just do a big question
answer session and get through
everything so if you can just hold on
and you'll hang out in a live chat I'll
get your question if you can't stick
around you can always catch the
recording of this later on and I'll
answer your question you know whether
you're here or not and and then it'll be
recorded for you to to check out
whenever you have time alright so let's
see so a little bit about what's going
on here maybe if you're not that
familiar with jQuery this looks weird if
you are familiar with jQuery this is
pretty standard so we're just kidding
so we're binding the submit event of our
form so this is the idea is the
announcement submit form and on click
we're going to do something so we've
passed in the events we have access to
that the first thing we're going to do
is check the length of our hidden
checkbox so this is our security on the
form right so I don't even know if this
still works anymore but the idea at one
point was like if a bot is trying to
fill out your form like a spam bot then
they they would check the hidden
checkbox because they would see it in
the markup but a real person would never
see it and check it so so if the hidden
checkbox is checked then you don't
actually send the data right so that's
where we're checking there so first
thing we're if there's a request going
we abort that request and oh man I'm
seeing lots of variables here instead of
constants Wow so here's our form
container and we're just saving that to
a variable so from now on dollar sign
form is our form and we don't have to
keep writing this selector anymore so
we're going to get the inputs from form
so we're finding all the possible inputs
in that form so we're getting any
element that is an input a select a
button or a text area and then we're
initializing some variables here for
name value and iterator and then a
checkbox we're grabbing the form
elements let's see find on input type
checkbox' all right so this is getting
inputs but we're excluding some things
we're excluding checkboxes we don't want
the hidden one we're excluding the file
type input and we're also grabbing
uploads
like remembering this as I go along so
and remember it was nearly two years ago
that I wrote this so be kind as you look
upon my spaghetti code alright so we're
going to serialize the data and so
here's what we need to change right now
we're checking local stores the profile
that we have saved after someone logs in
for the email we don't want to do that
anymore
we want to grab the email from that form
data all right so let's see what the
best way would be to change this we are
okay I forgot I'm sending this all to a
Google sheet and then from there from
the Google sheet the email is being sent
okay so I don't actually have any code
that handles emails all right sometimes
it helps to just look at your code even
if you wrote it all right I gotta take a
break for just a second because it is
super hot in my office I'm gonna take
off my sweater and then get back to it
actually it's a bin all right it's been
five minutes so I'm gonna take on my
sweater and then we're going to I'm
gonna go to the live chat answer some
questions read some comments and then
we'll come back and we'll grab that
email from our new email input and that
should be it
there's one other place in the bulletin
where there's a typo
so maybe we can find that and fix it and
then we can push all this to production
and hope hopefully it all works all
right I'm gonna scroll all the way to
the top of the live chat sorry if I seem
a little bit distracted for some reason
like all these songs that I don't like
keep playing on Spotify it's just
bothering they think and then I keep
switching them maybe I should just
switch playlists
alright there we are switch playing this
should be a lot better all right rook or
Nicki says old-school app made in 2016
sounds about right front end moves so
quickly
yeah for sure see it's a lot of you
saying hi I'm just I'm just to
collectively say hi to everyone there's
a lot of people in here
they're nice that's crazy so old haven
ich if you're still there I didn't see
you at the beginning there but thanks
for watching AHA John Hanson says hey
all what jQuery Hank it's just kidding
all right so Mari Marius let me know if
I'm not pronouncing that correctly the
Marius says up when the Mario says had
depression too and help get out of it
through exercise also says I'm so glad
you're doing better talking about it
it's a good move too too much stigma
around discussing depression yeah I do
want to say too with depression I've
fallen into the trap before of thinking
like hey I'm cured of depression and
like stopping my medication and just
stopping doing all these things that
helped me and then I would fall back
into it and it would take me a long time
to get back out of it and you know get
back to you know doing the things that
helped me out so I'm gonna try my best
not to fall into that again I'm gonna
continue with my counseling my
medication my exercise to be honest with
you the counseling the medication or way
easier than exercise for me like taking
a pill not a big deal
I'm going to go talk to somebody for you
know an hour a month not really a big
deal
my counsellor is great I always feel
like a million bucks after I leave
counselling so the exercise would be the
hardest but I just want to let you all
know that that for me at least
depression has never been a thing that I
could just like say wow I'm cured it's
gone it always comes back sometimes it
takes longer than others but you know if
you're in that place you know don't
don't feel bad about I think that's just
kind of the nature of some types of
depression med asks why did you get
depressed in the first place I don't
really know you know why it was it's not
like an event happened really that made
me really depressed it's more like well
as far as my doctors say it's more like
a chemical imbalance like there's you
know serotonin and different things in
your brain that regulate your mood and
my brain is not producing enough of that
and certain things can help you get more
like exercise or medications so that's
that's where I'm at right now just
trying to get back to
like normal levels of you know whatever
chemicals in my brain I'm supposed to
have they're all right hey I have some
of you are typing in Russian normally I
would put that in Google Translate but
I'm gonna go ahead because we just we
have so many comments now that I'm not
gonna do it right now maybe I'll do it
later on though
so apologies for that
alright it looks like a lot of you
thought that it was a really good idea
to have that this whole website that
we're thinking of doing with JavaScript
AF kind of the a place for developers to
showcase their work and encourage each
other
Jordan asked for links to tutorial
videos Jordan let me know what tutorial
videos you're talking about because I'm
not 100% sure maybe I missed something
in the chat or maybe I missed something
I'm not sure what I was talking about
there so let me know if you mean any of
the doriel videos that I've done on my
channel which I don't have that many
videos yet but the link should be in the
description to this to this video Oh
horseshit I know you're not here anymore
hardship but hard said might kill the
forum thing it's getting useless I'm I
don't I wouldn't kill the forum right
away I think it's a good thing and I
think I would rather not kill it but
maybe move it to a sub-domain and I
don't know you won't let me know what
would you think but I thought the forum
was really cool a cool idea alright so
it's been about five minutes I'm going
to go back to the code and try to finish
this up I'll come back to I left off in
the live chat after we finish this I'll
see Sebastian's in the stream and I
haven't seen Sebastian for a long time
so hey Sebastian how's it going
welcome back I'm really happy to see you
alright so let's see and I just realized
I haven't been using the Pomodoro timer
so let me bring this over this is the
one that I think this is the one Harsha
built yeah
so let's set this timer that way I don't
have to keep watching the clock and
let's grab let's see if we can grab our
e-mail so we're bringing this data in
we're grabbing these inputs and we're
finding this funny funny
I'm not sure what format we have this in
so I want to see I'm gonna do a console
log and I want to see what these form
elements are let's check it out let's
put something in here autofill some
stuff and submit and inspect it see what
we get
dev tools popped up on that other screen
and it's this one
announcement text email says good let's
make sure I don't have any more console
logs in here it's possible console
logging several things what one of 19
I seriously have 19 console logs whoa
all right let's get rid of a lot of
these console logs what was I thinking
19 console logs all right I'm okay with
with console logging this stuff for now
all right I have some well I have a lot
of stuff that's just commented out
it's always crazy to go back and look at
my old coat and just say what was I
thinking
all right so let's go
I want to make sure I know which
console.log this is so this is some es6
template literal syntax so I use those
back ticks and then everything in here
is a string unless I put it in with
within brackets starting with the dollar
sign and then this is JavaScript so now
I'll save that and I'm gonna bring this
over here make it bigger so it's
actually readable for you all let's
clear this out and now I'll put my email
back in and submit the air we are
sisters look at this object object okay
cool so we have an object alright I was
hoping that we would have an object
wonderful alright let's go over here so
what I should be able to do is just grab
that value let's get rid of this
when we get that email oh I see
so we are
let's take this out of here so we're
just going to define email here so it's
still available in the scope that we
need it but then within this function
where we're serializing then I'm going
to go here and say if name equals oops I
need parentheses so if name equals email
then we're going to set email equal to
the value all right so now since we
defined email here even though we're
inside this this loop here we're gonna
give email this value and then now we
don't have to change anything else
because anywhere that we're using the
email variable down here it's just gonna
pull this value so could we possibly
refactor and make it a little bit nicer
probably but as I said a few minutes ago
this this particular update does not
justify spending any more time than we
absolutely have to and we're going to
replace all the code sometime within the
next a few months or so okay so now
let's try it out
so I'm submitting it it says it's been
since although the result says error
email invalid email I should let's clear
it and then try it again
I I'm not sure if that was from this
time or the last time
all right so in I'm getting an error and
a success well the only way to be sure
is to check my email
so I do got my email open on my other
screen and let's see where I should be
getting an email at my gmail account and
another email at my work account okay
all right so we have an issue so right
now it's coming through the message is
coming through as test but the email is
coming through is undefined so let's see
what value were actually getting here
now there's two ways that we could
troubleshoot this right there's multiple
ways so we could go in dev tools and
check out the value of this or we could
console.log console.log would probably
be faster at this point but I would like
to show you another way that we could we
could get this so I don't usually do it
this way but it is it can be really
useful so let's check out our sources
and Wow so many things well how do I
have so many sources you know these are
all my there we are
alright so let's go to our forms and
let's check out email so let's put in
break right there so let's redo this and
now we're gonna go to submit
announcement and we'll put the email in
or submit and we have a break point now
right so I've added the break point so
the code stops right here
and I can check it says all right the
email name equals no space
all right so this looks kind of weird
our serialized form elements end up
being email equals Jessie why go at
gmail.com and undefined equals and
announcements that so we're doing
something wrong let's figure out what
we're doing wrong here where are we
getting that undefined from
you know what I believe we're adding we
do need to do some stuff down here I
think yeah we do all right let's go back
to the code I was a little bit let's see
all right
King Darcy's one of C's my mistake
hahaha good look good look at that
good catch those equals all right thank
you for catching that you all are great
on that you always catch it before me so
yeah I was using a comparison instead of
assignment right so I was using the
three equal signs instead of one so
that's that's good but then I also
remembered that with the serialized data
why am i serializing the form elements
and then making the serialized data am I
even using the serialize form elements
anymore
I want to see what I'm doing with these
one two three
I'm not even using these all right I'm
gonna leave it alone
this definitely needs refactored there's
stuff I'm not even using and we'll leave
it alone but it should it should work
all right let's see I think that I
pulled this code from another project
where I did need this and I just left it
in there never took it out
let's see
all right when you refresh it should
have refreshed I don't know what oh let
me take this up and let me make sure I
saved it there we are
now let's give it another try
all right yay all right wonderful I've
received the confirmation so I received
a notification at my work email that
someone submitted a bulletin and then I
received a notification at my personal
email that my submission was received
awesome very awesome
all right cool okay so it works so the
let's let me check my timer whoops all
right so I have about ten minutes left
at this point I want to very quickly
find the typos that I had which a
co-worker of mine found it so I'm going
to go to my slack messages and look at
that again
okay great
on the bulletin help page okay so it's
on the help page which listen help I
don't even remember what the help page
is is it okay it's a separate it's a
totally separate page okay let's see
hopefully I actually have it in here but
it will be suppose the dist index hmm
help all right so have a whole nother
folder that's for help
let's look at the index and see what we
can do
all right so it says experience is
misspelled expe r IE n c e h PE r IE NC
all right cool let's just well that's
too much let me make sure I'm not using
it anywhere else
expe o the end all right so that's not
coming up at all good alright so that is
ready I do have a dist folder let me see
strength Inc how I got this help alright
so help is included in the dist so I
have this set up that I can just use
gulp dist to make this ready but the
last time I tried to run this it didn't
actually do what it needed to do to all
the proper file so I'm gonna go into dis
now and make sure that we have changes
in the proper file so it should be index
and then that forms dot J s and we also
need to have index dot HTML within help
change as well so we're in the dist
folder it looks like help did not change
so we're gonna I just I'm just going to
manually pull this over for now you can
see like all the little places where
things just did not get it it's just not
good there's just little manual things
that need to be done the build steps are
just aren't good like compare that to
something like using create react app
and having all that done for you and and
it's consistent it's reliable it's just
a huge difference alright not that you
couldn't do that in an app like this but
it's not like it's not like I had an
all-in-one like this is going to do
everything I wanted to solution
alright so that's there we can close up
this help and our index dot HTML and I
have great okay so check our status just
to double-check at this distance
awesome now the next step is let's do a
commit let's say an email field to Miss
submission form and we're gonna push
that up to get up so again I apologize
this is a private repo so you can't see
the changes and then now I'm going to do
fly production so I'm using an NPM
module called flight plan which
basically goes into your server and
copies over your files into the right
folder and it's really fast so that's it
that should be working I'm going to
double check
by going to the bullets in the live
version and actually let me bring this
up on my screen
No oh let's see all right so it's not
working now but this would be a good
test so this is the new login system the
new possible way to log in that I'm
going to test right now I tested it
yesterday but can't hurt to test it
again so now I've logged into our the
university's single sign-on system that
they call access fus I clicked
University bulletin we just saw a second
ago I was not logged in I click that and
now I have access to the bulletin but
there is no login info saved for me but
if I go to submit announcement no no did
not go there
maybe there's some cat there we go
it was just caching all right cool so
now I have the email files let's do a
live test of this and submit submission
has been sent let's check my email to
verify yes I just got verifications on
Gmail and on my work account wonderful
all right cool so everything worked out
today maybe I'm better with jQuery than
I am with react usually I break
something with react oh wow so hopefully
I I was trying to do a couple of things
with this stream like other than just my
normal like watch me at work you know
type of thing and that was show an
example of how I used to do things and
kind of like hopefully see how far I've
come and and really not that much time
and also show an example of how things
can just get really out of control when
you try to like hand code everything and
not use something like react or angular
or your view to structure your
it's possible I met all the user
requirements with this it works it's
reliable but it's it's kind of hard to
maintain there's not really that much of
a logic to it until I go back in and
just look at what I've done so anyway I
hopefully that was like somewhat evident
to you all hopefully I don't have to go
back in and mess with this very for very
much longer and we get that react
version going so with the time we have
left which is only three minutes so I'm
not going to do any more code now I'm
going to go back to the live chat and
I'm going to answer all your questions
read out comments and so anything that
you want to talk about put it in the
live chat let's scroll up okay
Zuber says no fireplace please instead
use Postgres alright so Zubair if you're
still there let me know why you don't
think firebase would be a good fit for
this Anne Hale says MongoDB we can
definitely look into using [ __ ] for
sure
oh okay hard [ __ ] mate that's right okay
so I don't I don't know if our should
still here or not the Harsha did make
that chat app with firebase so I'm not
sure if he shared that with everyone in
the live chat but I I remember logging
into that before so that's awesome
so since Harshit is already familiar
with firebase that might be a good way
to go though just to save the time of
having to learn something else
Anoop says horseshit you're pumped up
yeah hard should it always has a lot of
enthusiasm I really love that about
Harshit and he has the skills to back it
up so Nicky says firebase is pretty easy
to use but apparently gets expensive
when your site gets popular all right I
can see that but I wonder is it more
expensive if your site at really popular
is it more expensive to use firebase or
would it be more expensive to try to do
the same thing by scaling like manually
scaling up servers and handling all that
so ideally if our site they'd get
popular we would either get some funding
from investors or donations or let's say
advertising or you know probably like
job listing types types of things I
think a job listing would be the most
useful kind of advertising for
developers because developers probably
are looking for a job or at least would
like to see what's out there if we start
if we did would do advertisements for
products I mean it could possibly be
useful but I could see that becoming a
little bit I don't kind of more annoying
that's just me I don't let me know what
you all think
on how us if there was a repo of the
project that I was talking about and
this is that JavaScript AF project we're
talking about the beginning I haven't
made a repo yet JavaScript there made a
repo that's just gonna be like a static
HTML site just to kind of get the layout
done which i think is a great idea
because it at least for me a lot of
times a static HTML site is just so much
easier to to do things in to make like
UI changes you don't really need to add
all that other stuff that comes with
building out react you don't need you
know at that point once we're you know
pretty satisfied with the UI then we can
always start making that UI in react
kind of like how we did for cat a
chemical Institute but we're gonna do a
better job of it
guitar says M lab is free check it out I
think we've worked with M lab in the in
the past on houses MongoDB Atlas has a
free version cool thank you for all the
the suggestions here I really appreciate
this ambition says do you code on the
weekends sometimes it depends I really I
try to save the weekends for hanging out
with my family but when I was doing the
Udacity react nanodegree I I coded on
the weekends when I have a client on the
side I code on the weekends so it just
depends on what's going on right now my
wife is doing she she's doing to like
boot camp programs at once so she's
gonna Udacity nano degree and she was
doing the flat iron boot camp at the
same time so the weekends like she
needed all the time on the weekend to do
that she just graduated from Flatirons
boot camp so maybe she won't need as
much time we'll see so right now I'm
doing
little Cody on the weekends but that
sometimes I do a lot it just depends
Zuber asked if javascript err and hard
[ __ ] username used by the same person
oh no no it's dude JavaScript and
harshin or two different people
michael said just got here and i think i
really missed the most important part of
the chat all right Michael if you're
still there I guess just go back and
watch their recording I don't sorry I'm
gonna need a drink after fit and I can't
get rid of mic off it's not nearly as
bad as it was the last week but it's
like still there let's see I lost my
place here
Stephen s if if we're gonna cry when we
see this meaning my jQuery mess Alexis's
jQuery is still used to s go yeah yeah I
know it's definitely still still used
Stephen says Jessi's confidence level is
scaring me today I'm not sure what you
made does it seem like I have a lot of
confidence today or not a lot of
confidence it feels like I'm the normal
amount but I don't know and is that a
good thing or a bad thing if I'm more or
less confident
Zuber says think about parcel jazz okay
I haven't heard about parcel jazz
Siraj says parcel is the new build tools
oh okay
and Mayer says partially I'm loving
alright wow I'm totally like out of the
loop here I didn't know that I don't
remember parcel Jess at all I'll
definitely have to check that up the
JavaScript just says if you want to talk
more about the project you can DM me on
insta yeah me as well you know there's a
variety of ways to get in touch with me
so whatever way is most comfortable to
you you know just let me know
email Twitter LinkedIn Facebook one of
the Instagram any of the social media
stuff I'm on just you know message me
all right Michael Chris has defined
spaghetti
yes so when I say spaghetti code usually
it's just like to me I don't know if
there's an official definition right
like it's it's just kind of like a term
that people use to describe code that's
kind of like gotten out of control out
of order it's it's not separated out
logically so that was that's what tends
to happen on some projects that were you
either and it doesn't you don't have to
use jQuery for to turn out a spaghetti
code you could be using vanilla
JavaScript you custom make everything
like the routing and all that which is
great and it could be really clean at
first when it's small but then you come
back in later on and sometimes you have
to add a feature here there it doesn't
scale well you end up just adding on
pieces of code sometimes you don't
remove old pieces because you need it
for this one thing and then later on you
may not need it anymore but you don't
remember that you don't need it so like
I went back in and found a variable that
I I wasn't using at all so evidently
when I was working through that I left
it in there for a reason and then forgot
to take it out so that's kind of what I
mean by spaghetti code it's all jumbled
up like spaghetti and it's hard to take
it apart right it's hard to just take
like one strand of spaghetti and
separate at all you know with before you
had to stick your fork in and do that
it's hard so in the same way it's hard
to just separate out parts of your code
like you could and react right like in
react you have your component if you do
it right you know you could remove that
component and pop it in another project
and with minimal changes or sometimes no
changes it can work hopefully that makes
sense let me know if it doesn't or let
me know if I'm wrong about spaghetti
code it means something totally
different than I think it means
see
Gander 7 says I watch from work and
couldn't pay attention because of Ward
discussion when you were pitching an app
idea at the beginning could you recap if
you figure out what I'm asking
yeah sure Gander 7 I mean the best recap
is going to be just to watch the the
replay but just a very short recap is
it's going to be a website where
developers can have a profile on there
where it'll just you'll sign in with
github it can pull data from about your
repos and things and you can share
projects you're working on and talk with
other developers and it could be a place
to you know highlight your work I'm kind
of hoping that it would end up being a
place where the focus is mainly on
projects especially maybe smaller more
obscure projects that are really cool
the people working on to kind of bring
it to the community and you know get
some more exposure for that and also a
place where I mean let's face it like a
lot of the other social media places
they're all this other stuff aside from
coding right so it would be nice to have
a place to go where the focus is mainly
just you know coding and developer
related stuff and not necessarily you
know other stuff that's going on in the
world there's it's important to talk
about other things but sometimes you
don't want all that other distraction
around so this will like be purposely
focused on one group just developers and
only on topics that relate to to
developers
on Hill says we can open an issue with
the subject about this project or
JavaScript er you can write the
description of the project in the readme
of the repo yeah that's actually a great
idea thanks for that I know we should
definitely just explain everything and
have it there for everyone to see
old sauce says why is jQuery so bad
where is where it's best use and where
you don't have to use it all right so
yeah I guess I don't want to give the
impression that jQuery is terrible to
use because I think some people it seems
like they believe that but I really
don't believe that I think jQuery has
its place I will say this if you're
working with react you should probably
not use jQuery because any Dom
manipulation with jQuery is going to
circumvent reacts you know the component
lifecycle so you're not going to get
that you're not going to trigger a
rerender with within react you really
should do everything like that within
state so try to avoid it with react but
if you had a project that was not react
based than you wanted to add some jQuery
stuff it could be a very helpful library
can help you do more in less time than
if you try to do it all which is vanilla
JavaScript jQuery can be very helpful
especially for beginners we're just
trying to get started and get a feel for
doing things I mean yes I think we can
all agree that learning to do things the
vanilla JavaScript way and the long run
is very good for a developer but
sometimes newer developers need to have
some successes and need to be able to
build cool things early on to keep their
spirits up and to make it through this
you know we all know there's ups and
downs you gotta have some thing to look
back on to say wow I did that to get you
through those Downs
I think jQuery you can very very quickly
be able to make some cool things also
you know people talk a lot about how
it's bad that jQuery
is this big library you bring in and
sometimes you only use a tiny piece of
that library well the fact is that most
sites on the internet use jQuery so the
odds that somebody already has that you
know cache somewhere especially if you
use a CDN are pretty good so the the
cost of that size of you know jQuery is
really mitigated by that so all in all I
I'm not if you use jQuery I'm not at all
trying to say you're bad develop or
anything
obviously I've used a lot of jQuery on
projects I even usually carry on a
project within the last year that we
completed so I will say this in terms of
just don't use it if you don't have to
if you only need to use a little bit of
jQuery it might be worth it to look up
how to do it with another JavaScript
yeah so that's my take on it if you
disagree please let me know in the live
chat or if you agree but have something
to add to that please let me know
see
[Music]
started
then this is hello from Russia hey how's
it going thanks for joining us no my AB
said is that visual code on Linux on
houses Syed yes I use it on the moon too
yes it is available on on Linux yeah
Dennis wants to see my plugins for
Visual Studio code sure let's view
extensions alright here's what I have
let me get rid of these it's not gonna
let me alright so here's what I have now
most of these extensions can be added if
you just get the react food-truck
extension react food-truck will
automatically add a bunch of these in
but if you do that I highly recommend
that you disable import cost because it
uses a lot of resources on your machine
and it caused me to drop a lot of frames
in my streams
Harshit said it either crashed or almost
crashed his computer so yeah so just be
aware of that if you end up getting
react food-truck
so all I guess I'll just scroll slowly
through this and then if you want if you
need to pause on one of them just you
know what you can pause the video or go
back and watch the recording javascript
or says I hate depression I suffer from
it as well as anxiety yeah yeah for sure
the anxiety occasionally I have trouble
with anxiety but I've been it's been
good I used to have panic attacks but
it's been years since I had a panic
attack and I really like I'm a lot
better with that John Henson says about
jQuery the jQuery is not bad though it
does not run natively inside a browser
therefore a library needs to be running
inside
browser in order for it to call the
JavaScript so there's data overhead that
is that's well said so I definitely
agree with that his access I went
through a two
Oh Peter says Visual Studio code is also
available on Debian and Red Hat Patrick
says Patrick O'Donnell says hey walking
20 minutes a day is all the exercise you
probably need it or wonders good luck
cool yeah actually I've heard that my
wife was telling me that she read that I
don't actually need to exercise for that
long to get the the mental benefits so
I'm gonna keep that in mind
but so I made a room for myself that if
I'm exercising on the exercise bike I
get to play the Nintendo switch so it's
incentive for me to play otherwise my
kids always want to play and it's like I
just don't get to so I kind of want to
keep exercising for 45 minutes because
you can't get that much done in 20
minutes right but anyway I'll keep that
in mind because sometimes if I didn't
get my full 45 minutes in I would feel
bad about it which is I didn't want to
feel about I'm exercising so I can feel
better so I'll keep in mind that I
really don't need that 45 minutes and
that's just extra I think you know that
that'll mentally that'll be better for
me
Dennis said I can translate from Russian
if you need oh cool cool thank you
Blake says why the dot af you know the
UM alright I could say okay Michael
criolla explain that all right thanks
thanks for Michael yeah I just got the
domain name is kind of like a joke cuz I
thought it would be like it'd just be
cool to have I wasn't sure what I would
do with it so that's why I got it I just
it like I realized that dot AF names
were thing and you could actually get it
it's the Afghanistan like code so I
immediately just started typing things
in to see if they were available
and JavaScript was one of the first ones
I tagged in it was available so I got it
JavaScript er says I'm getting a lot of
good feedback from it awesome
my AB says yep I found a flat pack for
Visual Studio code cool I'm not sure I
don't know what flat pack does let me
know Sebastian says quick TL TL DR so
too long didn't read on the JavaScript
thing happens haven't been seeing the
stream in a while yeah well hopefully
you've you're still on and you've heard
me explain it a couple times so let me
know if you need some more explanation
though but I think we've got over - a
couple times down
Sebastian says hey I've been working
hard I have this week off so I'm
catching around awesome well enjoy your
week off I'm glad you decided to spend
some of it here with us Oh
Alexi said the chat has been buggy is
anyone else having a problem with the
chat
it seemed okay for me but I wasn't
really in it a lot I was on my other
screen
Sebastian says get a dot tk1
it's free and more popular what's the
dot tk1 am i missing the the joke with a
dot CK domain
Aleksey says da da f domains are
expensive where can I get that domain
cheap
I don't really know it was kind of
expensive it's more than I've ever paid
for a domains oh it was like an impulse
buy I was like oh this I just have to do
it so I don't I don't know if you can
get a cheaper I didn't find it anywhere
cheaper Michael says between yesterday's
group chat and now today's look at your
spaghetti I'm feeling better about the
code block I'm experiencing all right
well I'm glad I mean I always say this
if I want you all to see when I mess
things up because I think it is
important to see other developers
messing things up trying to work through
it especially messing up just simple
things like I messed up and put three
equal signs instead of one equal sign
right like especially for developers who
work alone or freelance or something
like it's easy to get the idea from
social media from other YouTube videos
that there's all these developers out
there that are awesome and the don't
make as many mistakes as you do but
that's not the case
at least I think it's not the case
because I make a lot of mistakes show so
I just kind of wanted to share that
right because we we don't naturally want
to show our mistakes right we want to
post a selfie online and we take 50
selfies and post the best one right we
don't post normally all the worst ones
right it's the same way with our code
right we don't post our terrible code
and we don't post to you know talk about
how much how the crazy ridiculous simple
mistakes we made so anyway my point is
that I'm glad that it was working out
that way for you Michael
Oh Michael said by the way the : in the
days remaining give is making my OCD
kicking super hard these remaining I
don't know where that div is alright let
me get rid of these extensions I kind of
want to see this this day let's see I
don't even know where I have these
remaining on here oh whoa
let's see I lost my place
sorry sometimes the chat just Scrolls
down all the way to the bottom
King Dhara aha so King Ghidorah kept
pointing out my mistake with the equal
signs he said I was going crazy over
here I know sorry it took me so long to
look over I just I always forget that
you all probably see it before I do and
I should have just looked at the
teachers I didn't realize that I had a
mistake for a while though anyways david
says Jessie you remember our venerable
code opulent and imperial gazing proudly
from its stoic perch above the page
alright that's a different one today
David
I'm wondering so David is that a quote
from something because I don't I don't
really know what it's from anyway let me
know
all right so javascript is made an issue
in the github repo on on javascript or
github account where we can all discuss
the project
max put a like a sleeping emoji so I
don't know what I was doing at that time
in the stream but it must have been
boring
sorry max King Doris says the reason I'm
not a fan of firebase is because it
feels dirty to put all of the back-end
data management logic in the client does
that matter maybe I'm using it wrong
I don't really know King Ghidorah
I like I said the only thing I've seen
about firebase is from YouTube videos I
haven't actually used it yet I'm gonna
have to talk to some people that have
used it I know hard [ __ ] has enough to
talk more with hardship and maybe I'll
just try to you know reach out to people
to see if someone can fill me in on the
pros and cons of using it
King Doris's and I know firebase
functions are a thing but I haven't
heard much about them yeah I haven't
heard anything about them either
Jordan says go server list with AWS yeah
I'm like it I'm open for any suggestions
on this right now I just threw out
firebase kind of to kind of get things
started get the discussion started but
the way I look at different technologies
is you have your user stories you know
what you want to accomplish now find the
technology that will accomplish that the
best way
the quickest way the cheapest way what
you know whatever you needed to do find
what's going to get that done for you so
I'm not tied to any one technology it
would be nice to use something that I'm
familiar with there'd be less learning
involved for me I'm not opposed to
learning but I just know like I'm
realistic with my time to know if you
know I might not it might take a lot
longer if I have to learn something new
before I can help out on this project
Michael Chris has no ads please no ads
JavaScript er says yeah no ads trust me
that Lexi said ads aren't bad take a
look at carbonize yeah I I don't want to
put ads on there like I said the only
thing they even remotely close to ads
that I'd be okay with or job postings
because to me like that's that's helpful
to developers right when you go on Stack
Overflow you see the job postings on the
side that never annoys me I'm I think
it's I'd like to see like oh yeah what
jobs are out there what are they asking
for what are the titles even if I'm not
looking for a job it's still nice to
stay up to date on that so that's what
I'm talking about
I really would like to stay away from
ads if possible I mean but all like
realistically at some point if it gets
really big in the cost for servers and
everything is really high something's
gonna have to happen it doesn't have to
be ads but something needs to happen so
that can be paid for I am NOT
independently wealthy
so either like Bitcoin has to get to a
million dollars
or I have to win the lottery or we got
to find some other way to this before
tea
michael says the customers who would
come to the site have a ad-blockers
install so it would be a waste of time
to set them up it could be I don't
really mind ads that sometimes it's
useful if they give me like targeted ads
based on my interests sometimes I see it
I'm like oh yeah I did want that thing
Alexi says I guess it depends on the
person I whitelist pages that I want to
support
I also whitelist youtubers I'll export
oh that's a good idea I never thought
about that but I don't run an ad blocker
on my regular browser I do have it on
one of my browsers but that is a really
good idea about whitelist things to
support the site's you do work I like
that Mikael says hi what are you
building in this particular stream I was
building I was doing some updates on a
jQuery single page application that I
had built two years ago and I was just
adding in a new field to a form and
connecting that up with we were sending
it to a Google sheet and then that would
be emailed from there
Oh Mykel creo sorry Michael so I thought
Michael had asked me to define spaghetti
codes spaghetti code but he actually
said definitely spaghetti sorry I went
through that whole explanation Michael
also says believe me I know what
spaghetti code is I have a pasta master
so sorry about that Michael well maybe
somebody out there didn't know what it
was so hopefully that was useful to
someone
Michael said Jessie developers need
their ups and downs to make the ups feel
better me you're preaching to the crowd
okay so quote quoting me and then he
says me you're preaching to the crowd
brother yeah I mean yeah that's just how
it is that's I think just the nature of
it that you you get sometimes you feel
amazing you build something really cool
you've solved the problem and then other
times it's just like you you question
your the decisions you've made in life
that brought you to this point so I
think as you get more experienced as a
developer the lows aren't quite so bad
I've and the highs are you're more
realistic about the highest right so I
don't really get to the point anymore
I'm like yes I'm awesome like I know
everything and I think that's a good
thing because I know enough now to know
that I'll never know enough right
there's always going to be more to learn
but I also know enough to know like all
right if I totally mess something up or
I can't get it to work like that's okay
it happens I just need to you know keep
working at it or you know ask for help
or do something so but I think it's
hardest on newer developers you know
they don't have as much time to be able
to look back on and say yeah I remember
that time when I couldn't get this to
work and I remember that time when I did
this and that was awesome so I don't
know anything to help new developers
kind of get past that to kind of keep
them humble on when they're really up
and to keep their spirits up when
they're really low I think is a good
thing and that's that's probably one of
the most important things I think new
developers need because there's a wealth
of information to help them but like the
emotional aspect of it is not it's not
as easy to find help with that
especially if you're on your own
David says I'm learning JavaScript now
and still trying to see if I should
continue or go to jQuery I think I'm
almost at the end of my JavaScript
learning David yeah I mean I you don't
need to go to jQuery right if you know
JavaScript well you can do everything
that jQuery can do and just plain
vanilla JavaScript there jQuery can just
make it will be shorter for you to write
even though like technically you're
adding in a lot of extra code because
you're you have the whole library in but
from your perspective which you actually
have to write could be less it could be
easier to reason about it so it just
depends there's a lot of different
things you can get into to learn though
with with Java scripts besides jQuery it
just kind of depends on what you want to
do there's so many I mean you can do
back-end stuff in JavaScript with node
you can do VR stuff with node now you
can do machine learning which I love the
script
I'm not saying javascript is the best
way to use machine learning the people
have strong opinions about that but is
possible you can even do Internet of
Things stuff with JavaScript so there's
a lot of different ways you could go
also says totally review with you Jesse
about jQuery good to practice and learn
and after that try react see David David
says are there things in JavaScript that
I simply won't need as a web developer
oh yeah absolutely
absolutely there's there's I've been a
web developer for I don't even know like
let's just say like five years give or
take a little bit and there are still
parts of JavaScript that I I've probably
never even seen it's certainly never
used so yeah you definitely don't need
everything as a web developer my method
of learning has usually been I learned
what I need to for a project
and I build on that sometimes if I have
time which is rare these days you know I
could read a book about JavaScript and
learn some things that I never knew and
don't really need right now
but once you start to get busy with with
clients or something like it's just
really hard to just study JavaScript so
if you're in a position of a student
that's great and take advantage of that
and learn a lot but if you're actually
trying to make money and have a family
or have responsibilities to take up a
lot of your time learn what you have to
learn to get the job done and try to do
your best to piece it all together on
kids please can anyone tell me which is
a good place to learn web development
other than free code camp code Academy
is good Udacity is good I don't really
do much on udemy but people say udemy is
good West vos has all these courses that
everybody talks about says how great
they are I haven't done one of the West
vos courses but a lot of people that I I
know are good developers say that the
courses are good so maybe want to check
that out
David says that Kevin Powell dev tips
and Brad if you see also have great
videos on YouTube that's yeah I have
never watched anything well I've watched
it it's but not the other two but I
really do like dev tips some of that
stuff is a little bit old but I think
it's still really useful a lot of the
stuff about CSS and just general design
principles are really good and the guy
who is Travis a Travis's are really like
positive uplifting personality I always
like that about the dev tip videos Alexi
says has someone done freelancing in up
work or some other platform I'm in the
urge for money I haven't done something
like up work but so I can't speak
personally from it but if you're gonna
do some sort of online platform I
definitely do one that makes you take a
test to get into and really like make
sure that you get paid what you're worth
some of them just let anybody in and
then you end up getting outbid and if
you get a job you have to get underpaid
like severely underpaid so that would be
my only advice and going with different
work things so I'm not familiar with up
work in particular so I can't say
anything specifically to that but just
in general like freelancing platforms
that's that would be my advice
Alexei says I would do websites for food
Stefan says what do you think about view
I have not used you I don't have a
personal opinion above you based on
experience but there are developers that
I think are great and that I respect
that love you so I have it generally a
good opinion about you but I just don't
really know enough about it to give you
more than that if anybody else has
worked with you before please let us
know in the latch at when you think
about it
Oh Michael Caruso is on the site between
the counters you have a days remaining
display with 1800 on the actual site
yeah this is yeah that's not me I don't
make that I don't manage any of the
content on this site so I can't do
anything about this these are like
pre-made in Photoshop or something
let's see so CMD in code so I'm guessing
it's command in code says do you think
someone should learn vanilla JavaScript
before jQuery or another library or do
you think it helps to illustrate some
fundamentally important concepts I have
some mixed feelings about this so all
right here's how I feel if you're having
like a free online like learning
tutorial for people to learn on their
own
I think jQuery can be very useful early
on even before you get to other
JavaScript stuff to build up some of
that confidence if you're teaching
JavaScript in a like a university I
would not go with jQuery first unless
the course was like I don't know like
web development for non computer science
majors who just want to get into
something maybe I'd do it then but if
you're really trying to learn
programming in Shawano javascript in a
university I would go vanilla JavaScript
otherwise if it's just an online course
center of course I would go jQuery and
like I said earlier I think the key is
you want to help people who are new who
are most like that on their own and
don't know other developers you want to
help them start to get that feeling of
I'm really building something cool like
to feel the magic of web development
right I mean like you understand I'm
saying with the magic like things
working on the page you click the button
and things happen like it when you first
do that it feels great like you're
creating things and and they're they're
cool so going in first what jQuery
allows you to do that and then if they
really want to stick with it they're
gonna eventually get into the vanilla
JavaScript like it's they're gonna have
to write so that's my take on it I'm
definitely open to hearing alternative
opinions about that too I mean I'm I'm
no expert but that's that's generally
how I feel about it I started out I
don't know probably with a blend of
JavaScript and jQuery I tried my best to
to learn both but realistically when I
had
projects that needed to get done I
turned to jQuery most of the time
because that was the easiest quickest
way for me to get things done it wasn't
until I really started getting serious
with react that I forced myself to learn
how to do more with vanilla JavaScript
so anyway hopefully that was a decent
answer to your question let me know if
it if it wasn't if you have any
follow-up questions Patrick O'Donnell
says funny thing about spaghetti code I
once did an app like that but it ran in
production long after I left the company
no one can figure out how to replace it
that's that's sure that's the other
thing I'm always worried like I want to
convert everything I'm doing to react
and have like very standard things that
we do like coding standard like style
standards and and all that so that you
know if and when I leave someone could
come in and very reasonably like take
over everything and figure it out but
when I have apps like what we just
worked on today I'm not confident that
that could happen but I hope this is
really the last thing that I built that
I need to convert over to kind of our
newer organized way of doing things
and then I will be at that point where
everything is at least somewhat
standardized with the accept that kind
of Kenko institute site I still need to
get some jQuery out of that site but
other than that like I'm almost to that
point and especially with all these
videos there's a video a record now of
my thinking so someone could come in and
if they really wanted to didn't know
something they could go right to the
video where we did that and find out
about it so I don't want to leave people
hanging if I do leave here I'm not like
I don't have another job offer for
anything right now so I'm not saying I'm
gonna leave but I just want to make it
easier for the next person if it happens
let's see
hüseyin says hey dude you have got a
nose on your face
you're right that's that's definitely
true I have one it's right in the middle
thank you let's see what are your
thoughts on react versus you I don't
know I answered a question by view
earlier so I'm just gonna stick with
that I don't know enough about view to
really give you a good answer and
reactors a few I will say view seems
cool but I don't know that much about it
and I really do like react I have fun
developing in react David said good
advice thank you you're welcome I'm glad
that that can help you out a little AK
acted to mind there's another cool front
end channel okay cool so it's a CA de mi
ND awesome thank you for for sharing
that
we're trying to get the Google
Translation so our ten-hour Tim said
akka divine is another cool friend
Channel so sorry I couldn't say right
off the bat it was in where they call it
Cyrillic characters Russian I guess so
anyway I did the Google Translate
hopefully that's that's correct for your
name let me know if it's not I'd like to
pronounce it correctly if possible
Hussein says yes I did an up work it
works only get hourly paid jobs with
verified payers okay thank you thank you
for adding that personal experience as
always I think one of the best things to
to be able to draw from when you you
know when you're considering doing
something like up work or even getting
with a new company being able to talk to
people who've been there or are there
that's gives you a lot of good insight
on how says Jessie can you mention the
name of the freelancer page you have
worked I think it was freelancer I think
it's called freelancer comm I did that
there was another one called thumbtack
and freelancer.com I probably made like
$15 from total I mean it was it was
crazy you're doing work for like I don't
know
like dollar less than ten dollars an
hour sometimes it's just it's it wasn't
a good experience and you have to do so
much work cheaply to build up your
portfolio and get a lot of good reviews
it's not worth it thumbtack was a little
bit different I think I got one client
from thumbtack and maybe made like I
don't know $150 total after doing some
stuff it was really like didn't make
much from it
michael says i spent 15 years building
casinos around the country and that was
the biggest thing I built that that's
the feeling I want these days from
coding wow that's really cool
she went everywhere and build casinos or
stuff that's that's cool so were you
like construction worker architect or
something like you don't have to answer
if you don't want to I'm just kind of
curious
Joshua says hello there watch some of
your vids like it so much I subbed right
now awesome thank you for subscribing
david says since back in JavaScript as
possible with node and the like can we
skip PHP in those I it's definitely
possible to skip PHP and other back-end
languages you can pretty much do
anything that you need to do with just
all JavaScript nowadays so I I know a
bit of PHP and a tiny bit of c-sharp and
a tiny bit of some other languages but I
rarely use them and yeah so it just kind
of depends on what you want to do if
there's a specific technology you'd like
to work with it uses different language
then you learn it but if you're not
really sure you know if there's no
specific technology like let's say if
you really want to work with WordPress
yeah learn PHP if you don't have
anything like that I'd say just stick
with JavaScript you know you can
front-end back-end for the price of
learning one language you can't beat
that deal Joshua says by the way is it
possible for you to make a C tutorial
series or an Android app development
tutorial you know what we are gonna do
some stuff with react native so it won't
be in C or Java or Kotlin or anything
like that it'll be in JavaScript but you
will be able to build Android and iOS
apps with it so we already kind of
started a repo for that and I haven't
done that many videos with it but I hope
to after I'm finished with this current
project that we're gonna be working on
until probably like the end of February
and then hopefully we can switch over
and do some more with react native which
which is what we'll do the Android iOS
stuff with let's see
heart says I love react to I am good
with front-end stuff now I need to get
into back-end what frameworks would you
suggest for a back-end EV like Express
everybody uses Express with node so like
I'm willing for these streams we use a
lot of react with Express and node and
we build a ton of stuff with that
michael says a slot technician kept the
machines running along with keeping the
accounting systems warm
ok cool very cool I have an uncle he
used to be a dealer that casinos I so
I've never really worked it one before
to be honest with you I actually have
never like gambled in a casino so don't
have a lot of like personal experience
with it but I do know I know a few
people that have worked at them there's
a casino somewhat close to where I live
javascript says are you talking what I
think you're talking about with react
native yeah well definitely so I
actually have several projects I want to
do with react native but this JavaScript
on a AF for sure needs to be done with
react native right like people are going
to expect to have mobile apps with this
this network I think that's that's a
given now if you're going to do
something like this
Mobile is just expected so and since
we're doing it with react it won't be
too much of a stretch to make it work on
with react native there's definitely
some some differences in the way you do
CSS and things like that
the differences in the way you do
routing but the logic behind it and
grabbing data and things for sure it is
going to be pretty much the same
alright Gander 7s2 leave a thanks for
watching and I think thanks for chatting
with us so hopefully I'll see you back
here and some other streams later on
alright so I'm at the bottom the live
chat now I have a few more messages
coming in but we'll probably be
finishing this in a few minutes here and
I've gotten a lot of messages so
hopefully I didn't miss anything very
important for work I think I'm good I'm
duck checking now I think I'm good umm
so let me finish up these last few few
messages here harsh says okay have you
ever tried using blue bird to cancel
promises if yes can you make a series on
that I have not used blue bird so sorry
I've never used blue bird I think I read
a tutorial on it or something at some
point like a blog post but that's that's
all my experience so I wouldn't be
comfortable doing a tutorial on it but
if anybody knows of a good tutorial with
glue bird you know please put in the
live chat so to at least have some
resources that I can I can give you
there Vivek says networking is a good
field
yeah for sure I actually took some of
like the Cisco Networking certifications
because I was going to get into
networking and then a lot of stuff
happened I ended up not getting into it
but I I agree let's see
vivix says this AI is good or networking
for to get a job in the future yeah I
think AI is gonna just be like crazy in
terms of jobs in the future it's really
cool I talked to a developer on
Instagram yesterday about it and she was
saying like she wants to get into
machine learning ai stuff and I'm like
I'm gonna be jealous of you when you do
because that's that's really cool stuff
let's see harsh says like CCNA yeah
exactly I was doing the CCNA
certifications just like cisco certified
network associate or something like that
yeah so I went through like they let me
break it down and I don't know how they
do it now but you took two tests so like
halfway through the course you take one
test halfway through you take another
test you have to pass both of them I
passed the first test and then by the
time I get to the second test I didn't
really want to go into network anymore
so I did take the test but I I didn't
pass it like honestly I didn't really
study it all for it so I I wish I did it
was kind of a waste all that time and
money to do it so I wish I would have
just spent a you know a few hours at
least studying and I could have passed
it but oh well I like what I'm doing now
so I guess it worked out
let's see all right I'm gonna wrap
things up now this was a great live chat
it's a lot of stuff and we covered a lot
of different things and we finished what
we wanted to get finished and in this
old-school jQuery app so hopefully I'll
never have to work on this again and I
have a few more things coming in cool
alright so nope no questions okay is
there a schedule for for these chats
I've been I'm trying to do the live
chats at 12:00 p.m. Eastern Time
every week day Monday through Friday
sometimes I have to change up the time
depending on what's going on my schedule
but if you subscribe to this channel you
should get notifications letting you
know when the chats gonna happen and if
you follow me on Twitter I usually tweet
about it beforehand I try to do at least
an hour beforehand to give everyone a
heads up about you know what I'm gonna
tweet or what I'm gonna livestream about
so alright I had a really good time I
really appreciate all your advice for me
and the live chat all your help and
questions so I will be back let me think
tomorrow all I should be back tomorrow I
have one meeting in the morning and I
think I'm free for the rest of the day
and so until then have a great day